[Musique]
pour recevoir les enfants
mais qu'est ce que tu as à sauter comme
ça nounours tu es bien agitée
aujourd'hui et hop là j'ai envie de
chanter patron comme ça en pleine forme
ce soir et dont le cheval ou ou le là
auront je manquais tomber un l'on dit
calme nounours in te fatigue pas trop
froid y est centrale
je sais me tenir teysseron dont avec
calme là on comprend
je suis donc content voir ce tremblement
et c'est pas pour toi l'amour c'est pour
envoyer à ta soeur et milliards oui
c'est ton madame emilien au bond avec
cette lettre
oui c'est pour lui demander si rémi toto
et fanfan pas venir jouer avec nous mes
petits neveux
on aimerait bien les connaître le but en
tuant bah ouais bien d'accord je vais
lui expédier sa part express dit ils
viendront peut-être aurais-je ayala
avait bien ce qu'on est content
à moi c'est la fin de la journée c'est
le moment de ce projet nous faisons
parmi nos amis ils s'en vont tous au lit
nancy elle note aussi sur son nuage
certain moment le marchand de sable à
temps il nous dira termine mieux et
dormait tous les deux non ça me bien
dans notre lit nos os x
bonne nuit chacun se voit porter
réfléchir je vais m'endormir je vais
m'endormir
ça va nous faire plaisir faire mon bien
les pompiers
on
au soir papa maman j'ai éteint les
lumières
heureux chez le petit
enfant je reprends monuc
je connais
ont sûrement
[Musique]
nicolas mas prônait
je mouille à dos
[Musique]
non
bonne nuit les petits
si vous êtes bien stage vous aussi et si
vous allez vite vous coucher demain nous
vous raconterons une belle histoire
c'est celle patron c'est une surprise
d'accord mon cher nounours allons en
route allons vite nous reposer nous
aussi bonne nuit des enfants à demain
hot 2
[Musique]